we turn now to the mass shooting at a
dance studio in Monterey Park California
the majority Asian Community is honoring
the victims of Saturday's attack while
struggling to understand how violence
like this can happen 11 people were
killed ranging in age from 57 to 76
years old Adam Yamaguchi grew up in
Monterey Park has more
all of us here believe in safe places to
raise our children overnight hundreds
gathered at Monterey Park City Hall for
Vigil with some of the survivors
reuniting for the first time since the
massacre we saw each other we went out
people hug to shake a hand 65 year old
Daniel Shu says he's lucky to have
survived as he witnessed his friends die
in front of him from the hail of gunfire
how has this affected you personally
memory by a memory won't go away from
close my eyes the scene keep coming back
shooting people running at the store
dance studio investigators recovered 42
empty shell casings and continue to
search for Clues as to why the 72 year
old attacker shot at the ballroom
dancehall he frequented before fleeing
the scene and later died from a
self-inflicted gunshot wound in his van
we hope to find a motive but it's the
one question we may never have an
absolute for all 11 victims have now
been identified their ages ranging from
57 to 76
among the dead are star dances beloved
manager Ming Ma
Diana Tom a grandmother whose family
said love to dance and may may none her
loved ones saying her warm smile and
kindness was contagious the Asian
American Community they called home is
in shock but remains resilient for me
it's the sacred Place Tristan Cabral
grew up in Monterey Park immigrating at
a young age from the Philippines with
his family this neighborhood is special
because Monterey Park has been a Haven
of acceptance for Asian immigrants like
his family I honestly really loved
um that the other kids understood what
it was like to live with immigrants that
they understood what it was like to take
different types of food to school and
there wasn't this
like oh that's weird Cabral says it's
low for his hometown has only grown
since the weekend's tragedy do these
streets look feel any different to you
it feels more treasured it feels more
precious
as investigators continue to look into
whether the suspect knew the victims his
former tenant told our La station
kcbskcal that he knew quote this thing
would happen sooner or later he also
said that the suspect would often
complain about who was not nice to him
at the studio Gail
oh boy thank you very much Adam I
thought that man said it very nicely
where you said everything feels more
treasured I think that's right thank you
so much